нічого нічого
Сьогодні він відповідальний за збір
пакунків з допомогою у цьому
волонтерському Хабі І знає про кожну річ
яка є тут ми помагаємось одеждой соди.»
дорослі наставники волонтери до яких в
штаб батьки особисто привозять сина тут
його навчили вести облік допомоги
складати її та відправляти в інші міста
що там ні в Днепр что-то в
Запорізьку область це збираєш Ми
сьогодні відправляємо я хвилювалась бо
це дитина але ж нічого він справився все
що він робить ніхто його не запрягає не
каже він хоче робить хоче Ні я знаю коли
є люди коли треба допомога два зелених
свистка і далі вже тут
перша зустріч дані з волонтерами
відбулася зовсім не тут де він зараз на
Київщині А за обставин коли він його
менші Братики І сестричка та батьки самі
потребували допомоги живучі у підвалі
свого будинку в бахмуті
пробила у нас п'ятий поверх повна хата
голубей
Ну і плюс мародер і в нас винесли все
родина Мезенцевих до останнього не
наважувалася поїхати з рідного міста
навіть коли почалася холодна зима без
електроенергії та опалення
не їдемо
просто не було куди був колодець Ми
ходили в колодец і брали воду пічка у
нас була своя як сказати кімнатка ми
туди спустили диван ми я троє дітей на
дивані А
Мій чоловік рядом з пічкою спав тому що
другу треба ночью подкидывать за таких
умов дані навчався у шостому класі
онлайн І лише завдяки місцевому пункту
незламності в якому був доступ до
інтернету туди хлопець ходив щоденно
навчатися і там вперше побачив роботу
волонтерів
туди а там телевізор работает новости
и так тепло
на улице холодно когда первый раз помню
пришли подарки дарить Я всегда
восхищался волонтёры
Не знаю Ну они такие
душой добре
і потом я захотел тоже стать лучшем хоч
как-то помогал там та Коли російська
ракета влучила в дім де жила родина вони
наважилися остаточно залишити підвал та
евакуюватися з допомогою поліцейського
екіпажу білі янголи Потім дорога потягом
до Дніпра
звідкимезинцеве вирушили до Києва там
вони вийшли на зв'язок з волонтерами
Буча хелп ми взяли родину Наступного дня
ми приїхали з пакунками бо в квартирі де
вони зараз мешкають також це
волонтерська допомога нічого Ну було
щось ну для родини трьох дітей мами папи
йде прекрасної песика Там нічого такого
не було і ми всі почали спочатку і потім
От так і познайомились А зараз вони
мають змогу жити працювати діти вчаться
вже тут у Бучі на свій день народження
18 лютого
загадав бажання завітати в гості до
волонтерів які допомогли його родині
побачити як вони збирають гуманітарку
для інших переселенців І нарешті
здійснити задумане долучитися до роботи
благодійників
волонтерська його волонтерська перше
завдання приїхала машина з Литви І
привезли гуманітарну допомогу при його
ось день якраз вигружав цю до
гуманітарну допомогу на Хабі
Так
І він приходить він спілкується Він
розмовляє він щось хоче він цікавиться
Він допомагає і тратить свій особистий
час на те щоб це зробити багато людей
так не роблять
вони не можуть дати собі самі Раду після
того що вони отямиться ні не можуть А є
люди котрі розуміють що треба допомагати
бо допомога як це знаєте цепна реакція
вона допомагає допомагає допомагає Я
пишаюся цією дитиною пишаюся Ну що поїха
ли
за три місяці дані Вже спробував себе у
різних ролях як волонтер та
найулюбленіша його частина волонтерства
розвозити пакунки з грундопомогою
особисто тим хто на них чекає цього разу
це кілька родин в Ірпені
рік уже дома не було
в мене діти з дружковки з Краматорська
[музика]
Ірина не може стримати сліз бо землячка
дані вона так само втратила рідний дім у
бахмуті каже на власні заощадження
винаймає з дітьми житло в Ірпені втім на
новому місці важко впоратися без
допомоги волонтерів а її щомісяця стає
все менше будемо держатися у нас хорошим
що все відстроїти
не можу стриматися приймаючи пакунок
допомоги від даній інша переселенка
Лідія вона втратила дім У сусідньому
місті в Гостомелі і вимушено мешкає у
небайдужих людей в Ірпені
Стараюся
не сиджу Коротше не Лежу не сиджу з
кожним і кожною кому дані везе пакунки з
допомогою від благодійників він охоче
знайомиться підтримує і розповідає що
привіз тут вам туалетний папір ось
кросівки
тут консерви
допомога це не просто ти кинув коробку
машину і привез и дал не это ну как-то с
душой надо делать вот так положил достав
и дал чтоб увидеть улыбки радости
спілкування ну нових друзів
Ми це розуміють як ніхто напевне
напевнений як ніхто вони розуміють діти
це дуже тяжко дані сам зізнається він
щиро співчуває і розуміє усіх кому
допомагає розумієте цих людей є Ти
прошёл жизнь в подвале вода колодцы день
сурка люди не чувствуют себя одинокими
мы им помогаем мрія дані в майбутньому
опанувати професію завдяки якій він
зможе бути корисним українцям у списку
хлопця поліцейські лікар-педіатр та
журналіст а поки каже його місія
продовжити навчання попри все і
допомогти якомога більшій кількості
таких як він і одного дня вірить Даня
Він таки зможе повернутися додому в
рідний Бахмут